- Well, Bindi and Chandler,
there's no segue for this,
from that sadness that
we just talked about,
but congrats on the marriage.
So what was it like, you know,
getting married in the
middle of a pandemic?
- [Bindi] Thank you.
- Thank you, yeah.
- [Robert] So exciting.
- [Bindi] 2020 was a wild year.
- Holy moly.
It was crazy because Australia Zoo
was actually temporarily closed
for a period of time during the pandemic.
So we got married,
and then our honeymoon was
taking care of 1200 animals
with no guests coming in.
- Yeah.
So it was a wild time.
- It was really crazy.
And then, you know,
you always plan your
wedding with lots of guests.
And I think it was just
us and the animals.
- That was pretty much it, yep.
- Very small, but, you know,
it was really, really special
and we're just glad to be married
and glad to be able to be husband and wife
while taking on this wild
2020 and new 2021, so.
- It's a silver lining.
You gotta grab every silver lining you can
when times are tough.
- That's it exactly.
- [Robert] For sure.
- It's true.
- I was just about to say the same thing.
It is a beautiful silver lining.
And actually I think it's beautiful
that you had all these animals around
like while you're getting married.
I think it's a really beautiful thing
that it's a part of what
your family, you know,
what you're the vessel for
and your purpose is in life.
And to have that a part of your wedding,
that's actually really cool.
Well, Robert, how did it feel
to walk Bindi down the aisle?
- Ah, it was amazing.
It was definitely just
one of the most incredible
moments of my entire life.
I felt so honored when
Bindi first asked me
to walk her down the aisle.
And then when everything
was coming down to the wire
and we were planning this wedding,
it was really, really hard
because, of course, there were no guests.
It was just a little bit chaotic,
but at the end of the
day, it all came together,
and it was just the most
beautiful moment ever.
I think for me, I was incredibly
emotional at the same time.
Not only being so proud for
Bindi, it's such a happy day,
but also kinda thinking, you know,
how much I wish that
dad could've been there,
and that was his job to
walk her down the aisle,
but I felt very honored to be there,
I guess, sort of on his behalf.
And I think we definitely
felt him on the day,
and yeah, it was incredibly emotional,
but just so special.
I'll never, ever forget
that, it was amazing.